c'est mon ticket c'est ce ticket qui m'a
permis de devenir millionnaire monty qui
gagnent alors le jour où j'ai gagné
c'est un lundi un lundi matin pas
forcément de pressentiment particulier
je me rends dans le point de vente je
passe mon ticket un message que je ne
connais pas sa fiche et là effectivement
à je reste un peu un peu stupéfaits un
peu perplexe donc ça commence
à monter un espèce une sensation à
mouiller au moment où beaucoup beaucoup
plus ce qui m'arrive qu'est ce qui se
passe ça y est c'est le grand jour est
donc belle reprend mon ticket je vais
dans ma voiture
miracle de la technologie le téléphone
portable tout de suite on regarde le
tirage donc après ma commencent les
quelques minutes de vérification qui
paraissent très longue mais qui en fait
sont très courtes on nous demande le
numéro qui est en bas du ticket pour
vérification et là on nous annonce qu
effectivement officiellement on est
heureux gagnants de la somme mise en jeu
donc quand on se dit ah ça y est c c'est
une belle journée qui commence si tous
les lundis poubelle comme ça ce serait
sympa et combien un million sur une
cagnotte de 29 ne pas trop déçu moi je
me dit pas clairement de 28,1 millions
quand même vous dites un million si on
sort dans les rues qu'on demande aux
gens si vous gagnez 1 million vous allez
faire oui oui
première chose c'est j'appelle ma femme
je n'arrive pas à joindre donc je lui
envoie un texto
assez simple photo du ticket elle était
peut-être plus si les règlements en fait
mais j'ai souvent mais tu m'énerves on
va perdre du temps pour que tu t'arrêtes
faire ta gris
on n'a pas forcément l'habitude d'avoir
des sommes comme ça qui nous
apparaissent devant les yeux et qui on
allait sur notre compte en banque un
j'ai pas eu souvent six zéros derrière
derrière le premier chiffre je te
rassurer tout le monde
et on revient un peu sur terre on ne va
pas non plus lancer des liasses de
billets à droite à gauche ou les ans
ferrari a un moment faut aussi revenir
un petit peu à la raison puis se dire
les finir un projet en fait c'est quoi
la première chose que vous faites si
jamais vous gagnez le tout le temps
était locataire bomba le projet était
évident
de devenir propriétaire j'ai passé
quinze jours j'ai dormi comme un bébé
j'avais la tête livre l'esprit libre le
ticket là on se dit bon alors faut pas
le perdre donc on va pas le garder dans
le portefeuille contre un bal à droite à
gauche on sait jamais un pickpocket dur
c'est vrai que là on se met un peu plus
tard psychoter donc nous ça a été dans
un petit secrétaire avec un petit tiroir
sous quelques papiers que j'avais mon
père au téléphone vélib voilà pas j'aime
gagner à l'euro millions il l'a toujours
dit il a toujours dit et il l'a fait
pour vous fait le choix d'en parler à
vos amis et vos parents c'est pas un
truc que vous cacher
imagine que la personne qui a gagné 220
millions sur la dernière grosse cagnotte
va pas en parler à tout le monde non
plus même dans sa famille ça peut créer
des jalousies détention enfin ça dépend
aussi du contexte familial mais voilà
avec mes proches n'ont même des amis
proches à qui j'en ai j'en ai parlé tout
de suite bas les gens étaient plutôt
contents quand on est dans le milieu du
travail et qu'il ya une super cagnotte
le vendredi avant de se quitter on en
reparle maintien ce soir je joue ça se
trouve lundi serait pas là et si vous
voyez pu c'est que c'est moi qui ai
gagné et c'est que les petits jeux comme
ça
[Musique]
voire président je sais ce truc comme
président
les voisins issa non non non non non
c'est pareil la voiture que je me suis
pris c'est pas une voiture criard nous
et c'est allé blanche n'y a pas de gros
aileron lui a fait du bruit parce que
c'est un gros moteur mais voilà ça
laisse quand même assez discret sap a
été quelque chose qui était nouveau où
les gens ont pu se dire tiens c'est
bizarre qu'est ce qui se passe des fois
je m'imagine des gens qui vont gagner
par donc 150 millions qui sont dans leur
canapé qui voit le tirage me dit ma
soleil vont rester soudés pendant quinze
jours dans le calcul
travailler encore non non non les
meilleurs chiffres à jouer les miens
mais je les donnerai pas si je le dit et
tout le monde se met à gagner
pour peu que moi je vais mieux pas là je
m'en voudrais pour moi un numéro que je
joue
systématiquement le 12 et des fois c'est
complètement différent rarement mais des
fois c'est on laisse libre cours aux
stylos d'aller naviguer sur la grille
parce qu'encore aujourd'hui de jouer oui
parce que c'est pas fini je reste
convaincu que je vais que je vais de
nouveau gagné alors comme ça marche une
fois pourquoi pas nous
[Musique]